[Musique]
et moi ça le jour se lève sur san
francisco la vue est assez imprudents
les carreaux sont ou bien sale donc sûr
c'est que ces pays paraît évident de
burbach comme ça les regarde et on est
vraiment dans les codes de san francisco
il ya plein de drapeaux dos un drapeau
français juste en face regardez-moi les
styles des parades que vous avez enfin
s'il voit un monde vraiment magnifique
on est aujourd'hui à donc à san
francisco pour aller voir l'impact de
samsung à les nouveaux smartphones qui
vont être lancés galaxy s 20 doit y
avoir le s20 plus s20 ultra il va y
avoir également dû pliable
donc tout ça je vous le montre
aujourd'hui on va faire un petit tour et
puis y aura plein de trucs avoir
première chose à faire on va se faire
comme d'habitude qui tourne la fiole
j'aime bien partager ça avec vous
regardez alors bon on hôtel qui est
vraiment cool dans le centre de san
francisco au père desbois ça comme c'est
tout mignon un grand lit super classe ou
y qui coin pour travailler de quoi poser
les à fabre ça je voulais pas les garder
moi ça comme s'écoule personnalisés
welcome aurélien granet au round 4 118
on est plutôt bien alors aujourd'hui la
météo on a un ciel qui est plutôt bien
ensoleillé 62 xacti des degrés
fahrenheit passer par les degrés celsius
tu sais qu'à vaches hautement climatique
mais là quand même
et puis si on va chercher par ici on va
se retrouver avec une petite salle de
bar garder la chaîne bien partager
l'intimité comme ça que j'adore le style
cet hôtel programme de la journée on
parlera le bail avec la presse française
ya plein de trucs à voir c'est
franchement je suis très content d'être
là pour vous emmener aujourd'hui à san
francisco et mon avis pour voir plein de
jolies surprises
[Musique]
jens est quelle pêche tu te regret j'ai
pas dormi je ne dormais pas [ __ ]
impact on est à cheval à une pac dont on
ait foule première fosse du est la
première fois aux us première bonne
bouffe on s'en fout un peu comme si tu
avais comme ses voisins des grands côté
mon père j'ai première fois aux us
première une pac lâché en passant par me
suis pas
s'installe on part à la fac de 200 sous
garde et commencer ou flat j'ai mis ça
juste parce qu'il ya la clim et qu'on va
se cailler les miches mais sinon il fait
beau pour voir qu'on est au mois de
février on est vachement bien
à san francisco je connaissais pas la
vie est cool et puis surtout je serais
content parce que vous savez j'ai enlevé
les génériques et quelques temps et
aujourd'hui du coup j'ai rajouté j'ai
changé avec elliot qui vous passez un
petit message avantage et ne montrent
pas ça je regarde toi
regardez-moi la fine fleur de la taxe
française waouh ça va nous dire pourquoi
et toujours les bons à l'arrière du bus
la félicitation
ouais
le lieu est juste officines je suis
ouvrier truc sans se croire dans la rome
antique avec des colonnes de partout et
là derrière vous avez un énorme bassin
avec je sais pas comment on peut dire ça
la regarde on est sérieux on a cette
photo ho là là mais quel artiste du
rhône artistes bien il est un artiste
sur le mettre dans l'eau il flotte
ils flottent çà devient rouge paris
flotte c'est pas mal quand même
are you mister jo jeunes non aux caisses
on rigole
c'est bon t'as ton masque on est protégé
à mon protégé d'un époux s'est pas passé
comme ça ça c'est le moment le plus
important de la conférence c'est prendre
des bosses est exactement
conseil numéro un pour tenir le choc oui
ça c'est de luz
[Musique]
bon voilà donc à même pas qu'il a
commencé à écrire des chansons bien peu
en hauteur sur ma chaise c'est énorme de
monde qui a de tous les côtés ça va être
un truc je prends juste d'un drone pag
ici à san francisco et crampagne de tous
les côtés du monde qui viennent des
quatre coins du monde
alors y aller petit protection s'est
toutefois vous inquiétez pour le corona
virus ils viennent prendre un peu
contrôlées température à l'extérieur
sans iphone tu êtes aussi un colt alors
du coup qu'il plaira
[Musique]
vous
oui dans la zone d'expérience ou roux il
ya tous les médias de la terre entière
qui s'en foutent royalement les produits
donc là et s'est vu les putts j'ai vu
j'ai vu une seconde édition spéciale et
ce vaste zone a cliqué 10 raclette
j'ai pas eu le
de cette vie c'est d'ailleurs c'est
bizarre la pêche de cette fuite
alors est-ce qui a démarché salon est
plus un français tu flippes galaxie des
prix quand j'ai acheté mon nouveau
smartphone - tu sais le nouveau
smartphone qui lobe le samsung galaxy
cette free
[Musique]
dans le studio creator et si c'est le
galaxy creator loange à san francisco il
ya eu le bac de tout à l'heure qu'il est
les trois nouveaux smartphones 33,4
nouveau smartphone de samsung que ça
c'est le galaxy s 20 il ya eu le galaxy
s 20 plus le galaxy s 20 ultra et puis
et bien évidemment le z flip qui est
juste là le pliable qui se rabat petits
formats où règne de l'espace ça je vous
le présente demain demain ou après
demain le temps de plonger de faire les
vidéos parce qu'il ya des avions je
rende son procès ce qu je file à l'ombre
enfin c'est toute une histoire mais ça
se passe bien
donc aujourd'hui je voulais pas être ce
smartphone la lorelei dernière fois ci
vous souvenez qui a vu effectivement les
galaxy s disent qu'ils sont sortis les
deux disent beaucoup plus tard et puis
c'est parfois une vache moins
intéressant et là une sorte trois
nouveaux smartphones
la gamme s'élargit avait l'année
dernière le s10 est plus là cette année
on arrive sur le s20 s20 plus et s20
ultra trois smartphones vachement
intéressant en fait ce qu'on voit c'est
qu'un changement et demi mon pass du 10
au 20 ya pas de s 11 et donc une
évolution de la gamme et puis surtout il
ya modèle beaucoup plus performant qui
va beaucoup plus loin
qui va jusqu'à un zoom x 100 alors
est-ce qu'on va jusqu'à faire d une
façon je ne suis pas nécessairement sûr
mais par contre c'est intéressant ça
manque vraiment la direction continue en
tout cas prendre samsung pour s'adresser
aux créateurs pour venir braga et
créateurs alors qu'est ce qu'on voit
avec ses smartphones et bien lorsqu'on
regarde ça effectivement c'est enfin un
gros focus au niveau de la photo - smart
faut que je trouve assez logique que ce
soit le s20 s20 plus est sera ultra
voulu tenir en main c'est bien ils sont
vraiment léger la prise en main est
vraiment qu'on gagne quasiment faire le
tour on a un écran qui est bon à s'est
allongée
la prise en main est bonne facile à
manipuler comment ça va écoute très bien
ouais bon alors vous avez lancé plein de
vos produits aujourd'hui ça me fout bref
pendant que monsieur samsung de la
journée donc trois nouveaux cas quatre
nouveaux produits aujourd'hui on va se
concentrer sur la lys brins s20 et d20
+16 valtra tout à fait qu'elle est un
peu l'adn global a déjà c'est quoi
l'idée de la gamme m alors elle va pour
commencer on est ravis de t'accueillir
ici à san francisco raison d'être avec
vous pour cet impact
merci et ben tu as découvert les
produits tout à l'heure l'adn de la
gamme est devant c'est vraiment la photo
oui la photo et la vidéo parce que ces
deux choses qui vont en sens
pour nous avec 4,4 innovations majeures
ok la première on va peut-être au détail
et après c'est la netteté des images
auxquelles le nouveau capteur la
deuxième set le zoom avec des nouveaux
outils permettent de faire des choses
vraiment tu vas jusqu'à fois sans avec
l'ultra jusqu'à 320 et lagrave hockey et
on se détaillera détaillera ensuite la
troisième chose à être une fonction qui
s'appelle single take qui permet d'aller
combiné de plein de modes en même temps
alors pour aller revoir des résultats
différents et d'avoir à jongler entre
les différents modes c'est à dire oui
c'est à dire comment est ce que tu donc
la voiture alors lien entre les gens il
ya un mode qui s'appelle single take
dans la parité
ouais et en appuyant simplement sur le
déclencheur ouais il ya un compte à
rebours de 10 secondes qui se lance ok
et on va voir le résultat de nos photos
avec un insulteur ultra-grand-angle en
mode portrait en noir et blanc une vidéo
en boomerang en hyper l'aps vont ensuite
choisir le résultat qui nous intéresse
pas mal du tout pour les créateurs son
bref c'est très pratique superbe
que ce soit pour les créateurs aussi
pour les photos et les vidéos du
classement est la dernière innovation
c'est toute la partie wicca hockey
puisque on va voir les vidéos en liga
mais aussi la possibilité d'extraire des
photos à partir de ces vidéos
et encore une fois c'est triptyque pour
tout le monde pour jongler entre photos
et des vidéos
génial parce que tu me parles public est
alors ça qu'aujourd'hui j'imagine que
commun des mortels se dit la cage de
même pas forcément chez moi beaucoup
voient cela comme en beaucoup c'est
l'art de mettre à teaser ça se
démocratise bien mais tout le monde
apprend quand la capca et on se dit ok
on s'embrasse matrones qui filme huit
cas mais je peux pas diffuser de l'a8
est natif sur sur leur écran à moins que
j'ai effectivement acheté le dernier
moniteur samsung avec de la guica mais
globalement aujourd'hui l'amicale
support alors c'est évidemment possible
d'aller diffusé l'avicca sur nos télés
ambika usage principal l'idée de deux
aujourd'hui sur l'a8 cas c'est qu'on a
deux avantages
le premier en vidéo c'est de pouvoir
zoomer dans une partie de la vidéo et la
ressortir de manière ultra net sans
avoir besoin bien complète et tu
redescends octobre exactement l'idée que
tu as beau et la deuxième qui est très
importante pour nous c'est que lorsqu'on
prend une vidéo we can oui on va pouvoir
dans la galerie une fois que la vidéo
est prise c'est repos sur la vidéo et
extraire on soit en une photo à partir
de cette vidéo là ok donc imaginons
qu'on est à san francisco en train de
prendre un beau paysage
ouais j'ai plus besoin de jongler entre
photos et vidéos ouais je prends ma
vidéo mika pendant 30 secondes ou que
sais-je
on est ensuite je trie dans ma galerie
en faisant pause et en sortant une vidéo
une photo par dont 6 en organique
alors ça tu l'as sur l'ultra tu l'a
surtout sur les geeks à ça c'est sûr les
trois produits sur les 3 way sli que tu
commences avec quoi 128 go de stockage
ouais parce qu'il faut quand même du
stockage couteau qu'il ya eu un cas tout
à fait alors il faut du stockage sas est
indéniable ouais on à 128 gigas qui est
déjà
déjà une belle offre c'est déjà pas mal
et en plus comme sur l'adn de tous nos
produits
un port microsd qui permet de rajouter
de la mémoire jusqu'à l'humain terrasse
sur les mardis ok cool
donc ça c'est effectivement c'est la
partie lui qu'à la partie single shot
j'ai compris tu fais tout en un an et
après tu auras fructueux de repos spot
n'a pas besoin de t'embêter exactement
sua choix que j'avais un tout petit peu
moins là dessus moi c'est là la petite
le petit point sont ici j'avais espéré
que ça me saoule puisse enfin pouvoir
nous intégrer la caméra sous l'écran ce
n'est pas pour cette version là
peut-être en 2020 ' tout cas je vous
invite à vous abonner parce qu'on en
reparlera de ça
j'espère vraiment que ça arrive à très
très vite - les smartphones je trouve
bien le design est vraiment coup on n'a
quasiment pas de bord en bas des bords
très très léger sur les côtés on est sur
8 gigas de ram 128 go de stockage de
base et on monte sur l'ultra jusqu'à 12
à 16 giga de ram on a du wifi 6 pour une
collection toujours plus rapide un
téléobjectif jusqu'à fois sans ouais
alors sur la partie zoom on va
distinguer l'aller s20 et lesbiens plus
d'un côté oui et le s dans l'ultra de
l'autre oui sur la lys basera plus qu'à
ce qu'ils ont à leur différend sur le
sgl us va influer sur la partie zoom on
va pouvoir zoomer fois 300 paires de d2
de débuter ok dit la terre c'est un zoom
optique c'est un zoom optique c'est un
zoom libre et cotait 1 x 2 optique il ya
pas d'optique du tout y at il des
hybrides donc c'est que l'hybride
exactement ok c'est l'hybride
mais le résultat pour l'utilisateur va
être digne d'un zoom optique au caire
votre supérieur pas de faire de netteté
est par contre x 30
là on va être en numérique oui donc
on va forcément perdre un taux de
qualité entre 3 et 30 ouais mais
toutefois un peu mais beaucoup plus loin
que sur un ace 10 par exemple on était à
x 10 ans nîmes et oui ok donc ça c'était
l'ès 20 exemple n'a plus est sur le ssd
ultra on va pouvoir zoomer x 10 sans
perte de netteté hockey et jusqu'à x 100
numérique est donc là pour aller
attraper le petit détail qui est qui est
vraiment au fond d'une scène où le
monument qui est un peu loin alors moi
il ya un truc je sais pas honnêtement le
cil fois sans a vraiment un grand
intérêt passe quand on regarde comme ça
bon ce qu'il en ressort c'est quand même
une photo qui a été lissée c'est pas un
truc hyper trouve par contre que ça
monte derrière c'est l'innovation est un
peureux de fuck d'aller chercher si loin
ça c'est marrant mais ce que j'ai
beaucoup aimée dans la version
logicielle lorsque j'étais tout à
l'heure c'est qu'en fait vous voyez vous
zoomez voyez votre façon mais des fois
on se perd quand on va chercher trop
loin quand on reste que je suis c'est
qu'en fait ça vous sort une espèce de
petites miniatures par dessus où vous
voyez avec un petit point rouge ou
est-ce que vous êtes dans un autre image
et où est ce qu'on est en train de jouer
et ça c'est vachement bien ouais ça
c'est intelligent comme d'usagé
c'est hyper pratique ça permet de ne pas
se perdre dans son zoom à metz et
parfois sans mais tu te perds forcément
si tu n'as pas ça tu te plaît et
notamment les dons qui est intéressant
aussi
c'est qu'entre
notamment pour les zooms x 30 et fois
sans eux
lorsque vous allez pré visualiser votre
photo avant de la prendre parce que vous
venez dans l'interface
à voir donc le rendu de l'image qui
apparaît ok mais une fois que j'avais
pris la photo il ya encore le processeur
qui va retravailler sur l'image et le
résultat dans la galerie et est meilleur
que ce camp pris le dessus qu'on voit
c'est parce qu'on éclatant dans les
grandes lignes ce qu'on va avoir oui
elle fait autant en photo tout de suite
ça à l'école y aura un problème
ouais tu as ça mais en améliorant fait
derrière tout à fait ok pour lui donc on
a toute cette partie avec le zoom
traitement photo oui quoi d'autre alors
j'y allais de la netteté des images
ouais ça c'est quelque chose qui importe
en partie culture rappelle que sur le
s10 on était à 12 mégapixels
oui en terme de nombre de mégapixels
lorsque intéressant sur l'ès 20 est bien
plus à de nouvelles traces et qu'on va
voir un capteur plus gros ce qui nous
permet d'aller augmenter le nombre de
mégapixels sans perdre en qualité qui
soit de jour comme de nuit d'accord et
du coup on va pouvoir faire des photos
de 64 mégapixels sur les bases d'un plus
tôt qu'elle est de 100 8 mégapixels sur
le hand ball trap d'accord quel est le
bénéfice pour de faible luminosité
alors ça va être déjà deux jours des
photos qui sont ultra net
lorsqu'on prend la photo même lorsqu'on
va se jouer dans la galerie avec son
doigt sur la photo elle va rester net
auquel ce qui fait qu'on peut aller voir
que un sujet qui a été pris un peu loin
reste reste net et on peut aller
extraire une partie de l'image hockey ou
l'imprimer emprunts de taille si on le
souhaite et
l'intérêt en basse lumière notamment sur
le culte rats c'est qu'en fait c'est
pixels vont fusionner oui on aura la
fusion de neuf pixels an 1,9 pixels on
est exactement dans connaissait le cas
de pixels en off du neuf succès l'anas
pixels en n'importe quoi parler d'autres
marques mais beaucoup de marques rendu 4
pixels 9 pixels en eau qu'est ce que ça
va apporter de plus
alors à quoi ça sert c'est que justement
de nuit 108 / 9 égale 12 puis toujours
été très mauvais en maths bon cette
division dans ce cas ne veut pas c'est
sûr mais doit tout va bien oui sans 889
égale 12 bravo on a dû fixer à l'impact
plus gros nourrit plus de lumière qui
rentre dans le capteur et des photos
ultra lumineuse en basse lumière
l'accord très bien ça j'ai hâte de le
tester
j'ai vraiment hâte de le tester je veux
pas partir avec aujourd'hui parce que
c'est pas encore l'instant mais ça ne
saurait tarder et justement abonnez-vous
s'est pas déjà le cas comme ça on va se
tester on retiendra vraiment puisque ses
smartphones 10 parce que offrait il faut
vraiment une très très jolis chronos
sont des smartphones qu'il faut penser à
protéger parce que ses smartphones là
sont très jolis son très beau monde à
éviter de les casser surtout que même si
vous avez un dos qui protégeait bien
évidemment l'arrière et que même si vous
le faites tomber normalement ça devrait
pas trop mal se passer
je vous conseille quand même deux
mineurs protège alors vous avez deux
solutions bien évidemment la première
c'est un petit peu peur qui va venir
l'entouré comme le petit bump hommes aux
partenaires rhinochill guen évidemment
vous prenez votre petit bump heures vous
mettez votre smartphone dedans alors moi
j'ai ici le bumper pour le s20 plus j'ai
ici en israël voyez un petit peu
l'erreur et oui forcément ici ça n'est
pas assez modèle c'est le coin des
créateurs dont il ya beaucoup de
créateurs il ya beaucoup de monde donc
vous prenez votre smartphone vous le
glisser dans vous le protégé tac tac
vous la gérez vous êtes tranquille ça
c'est vachement bien et vous avez en
plus ici de petites coques de protection
vous le mettez ça vous protège c'est
bien c'est pratique ça c'est super vous
avez une remise d'ailleurs avec le code
monsieur gros je vous ai mis les liens
en bas dans la description si vous
souhaitez commander votre smartphone que
ce soit le s20 l'oeuvre un plus
le xv à ultra et aussi les coques pour
le protéger faites le package complet
protégez vous sortez couverts comme on
dit chez nous comme seulement vous êtes
relativement tranquille toujours le
petit poisson qui est assez facile à
bulle a disparu est ce que tu peux nous
dire pourquoi alors l'homme bull
on est toujours une parce que c'est un
louis d'or frontale ans
de forme arrondie absolument sauf
qu'avant on avait sur le s10 plus
ouais double capteur qui était une plus
grosse bulle grosse tache sur l'écran
mais en guinée quand je dis ça donc là
on off ou samsung a fait le choix de
l'enlever pour garder uniquement le
petit coin sont plus petits plus plus
léger plus discrète alors du coup
objectivement l'appareil photo frontal
passe au centre
oui l'écran un autre un petit boulot
dans l'accent va dire et l'idée c'est
qu'on a plus de diversion sur l'écran
lorsqu'on va lancer une vidéo
le appareil photo frontal est quasiment
invisible donc c'est hyper plaisant en
ayant
la même qualité photo frontal que sur le
s10 quand même meilleur sur le s valtra
auquel de là on a 40 mégapixels en terme
de
d'appareils photo frontal des cinq
habitants sont le grand aussi ou pas
pour cette période y afférents
ok et alors de nuit du coup on va voir
la même fusion des pixels ou 4 pixels
ont fusionné en un et on se retrouve à
10 mégapixels en basse lumière pour des
photos ultra lumineux ce n'est qu'en
donc on oublie les photos de groupe ares
compte cette fois ci sur le
avec la plus grande on a la possibilté
de
d'agrandir un peu oui son chant ou
iphoto frontale mais il n'ya pas d'ultra
grand-angle ok ça marche qu'est ce qu'il
raconte d'autres ses smartphones alors
qu'est ce qu'il raconte d'autres il ya
un point qui est important précisé ce
que j'ai parlé de trois modèles en fait
il y avoir 5 mai en france
pourquoi parce que les s20 et l'ès 20
plus s'en sortir en version 4g et 5g
d'accord le baseball sera lui disponible
qu'en version 5 g d'accord ce qui nous
amène à cinq modèles différents et c'est
important de le préciser parce que du
coup la 5g c'est
les choses qui arrivent et a déjà fait
beaucoup de vidéo sur le sujet qui
explique cette technologie et nous ça y
est on se lance à fond à fond dessus et
on arrive en étant déjà prêt pour le
futur avec sur la 5g d'embarquer moi je
suis consommateur
je me dis ok aujourd'hui images on se
prennent le le s1 peu importe je me dis
j'ai un modèle 4g aux modèles 5 jeunes
modèles kg coûte cher que le modèle 5 g
jusque là ça se tient à peu près
forcément il ya des modems et compagnie
c'est ça on passe un peu l'histoire
ok pourquoi est-ce que je devrais
acheter le modèle 4g ou pourquoi je
devrais acheter le modèle singer alors
le modèle 5 gs qu'on remarque
aujourd'hui même dans la plupart de
nouveaux étudiants ont fait parce que
tout ça c'est des choses qui sont il a
réfléchi et j'ai bien étudié
j'espère évidemment c'est qu'on constate
que l'argument principal pour aller
s'équiper en produit 5 g en france
aujourd'hui
ouais c'est d'être prêt pour le futur
qu'est ce qu'on sait que le réseau 5g va
être en déploiement cette année cette
année et pour ça nous laisse la parole
aux opérateurs sur ce sujet
donc un produit qui nous permet d'être
très pour le futur ok là dès mars 2020
par contre pour ceux qui souhaitent un
produit 2,4 g uniquement parce qu'il
voit et c'est leur leur avis personnel
pas forcément encore d'intérêt a passé à
la cinq j'ai tout de suite on a un
produit 4g qui se retrouvent dans les
mêmes conditions tarifaires que le s10 à
sa sortie j'entends et qui du coup ne
pénalise pas les acheteurs si je
schématise un petit peu est ce que je
peux dire que les ce mode les modèles 4g
sont plus pour les personnes qui vont
habiter en zones plus rurales pour pas
forcément de couverture 5g en tout cas
d'ici agents syriens 2022 quoi imaginer
ça comme ça on sait qu'en 2020 c'est le
vrai lancement de la sandero franchement
il pas encore réellement là le temps que
les opérateurs se replacent d'offres on
sera sûr aller au milieu de l'année mais
à partir de mai normalement j'ai orange
nom se prononce ni sur un calendrier
parce que ça relève vraiment des
opérateurs j'entends nié sur un profil
type
oui c'était vraiment l'envi de ce guy
benoit passer ou pas touchés mais je
comprends ce que tu dis mais c'est où je
parle pas au nom de tous mais moi je me
porte vraiment en consommateur je me dis
ok pourquoi est-ce que si j'habite à
paris lyon marseille toulouse des
grandes villes la 5g va t'arriver
pourquoi est-ce que je devrais me dire
je vais acheter un smartphone kg alors
voilà ce que j'ai pas envie saint gilles
mais qui l'est plus c'est tellement vrai
c'est que j'ai pas envie en fait de me
dire la scène d'espacé pour moi j'ai pas
être payés plus cher ça m'intéresse pas
où est ce que je me dis mon smartphone
je vais l'acheter aller chercher un
device comme ça j'ai fait au moins pour
minimum deux ans c'est un des arguments
des profils qui sont hyper différents en
terme de renouvellement de mobile bien
sûr certains changent après un an
certains après trois ans nous ce qu'on
constate c'est que quand même les cycles
de renouvellement sont en moyenne de
plus de deux ans aujourd'hui et du coup
quelqu'un qui veut s'équiper en 5 g
parce qu'il veut être prêt aussi au
moment où la techno sera disponible chez
lui bien sûr on peut déjà le faire tout
de suite
il a le choix et même si c'est pas le
mois prochain il sera il sera équipé la
différence de prix est de combien entre
un modem 5 g un modèle 5g un modèle kg
alors elle sera en prix public conseillé
le lui conseille 100 200 non elle sera
deux plus loin 200 euros dont 400 euros
des 400 euros d'écart pour se projeter
un petit peu plus sur la version 5
ok ok alors mise à part ces points là
parce que tu veux tu chose à rajouter
alors qu'on s'est beaucoup paris photo
et vidéo ce qui pour nous la dn
essentielles du produit moins de 5 g et
après sur le reste de la fiche technique
on embarque tout ce qu'on sait bien
faire chez samsung wave part notamment
des écrans ils sont 40 maîtrisée depuis
des années chez nous clairement la
nouveauté c'est qu'ils passent ensemble
être deux fois plus fluide 120 sur les
trois modèles sur les trois modèles
jaliens sur les trois modèles dont
classe en valeur sont les biais
d'accords ça apporte beaucoup plus de
fluidité lorsque tu vas venir scrollé
sur l'image notamment lorsque pour des
gamers qui vont vouloir effectivement
avoir un truc très précis c'est vraiment
les usages principaux qui a pouvoir
ressortir d'un écran sans rien c'est les
usages principaux exactement ça par
contre tu va consommer davantage de
batterie on va consommer un peu plus de
batterie logiquement après tout dépend
de l'optimisation
que tu fais derrière donc on fait notre
possible de la désactiver le sens
inverse ou dans ton appareil ou pas oui
c activée en 60 hertz par défaut
d'accord vraiment ce qu'ils souhaitent
de l'acte iv qui peuvent le faire dans
les paramètres d'accord tu fais 60 ou
120 to switch la procaine très bien la
super et
et d'ailleurs je parlais des batteries
on va sur des tailles de batterie de
4000 à 4500 et 5000 milan perd facile à
retenir de base en eau ce qui devrait
assurer une très bonne autonomie
après tout dépend des usages de chacun
comme comme d'habitude mais pour ça on
est on est on est inquiet du tout
d'accord
évidemment on a notre dernier processeur
exynos 1190 qui embarquait pourquoi
j'insiste dessus parce que quand on se
parle de photos et de vidéos
la capacité de calcul derrière
exactement la wicca aujourd'hui en 24
images par seconde en vidéo lorsqu'on à
33 millions de pixels c'est quasiment un
milliard de pixels qui sont analysés à
la seconde donc il faut un processeur
derrière qui s'est traité ça et c'est le
cas avec nos derniers processeurs super
et après comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
on à 128 jk stockage et si vous à ces
lignes et de souligner une dernière
chose ça notre interface one way points
2 annuel de qui et qui a encore amélioré
par rapport à l'an dernier c'était déjà
pas mal ouais ça on progresse bien sûr
interface donc non c'est vrai on ira
vers offre et l idée c'est que on a des
produits qui sont inquiets quand même
des tailles d'écran qui sont conséquents
qui on avait des grands écrans et on
peut quand même faire beaucoup de tâches
à une main un coin du maïdo et c'est
super g on parle de photos et de vidéos
souvent la vidéo c'est un peu le parent
pauvre du smartphone parce
qu'effectivement beaucoup de personnes
je ne pourrais pas forcément que de vous
tout de suite mais c'est vrai que une
fois de plus je suis consommateur et il
me dit ok je veux pourra me faire des
story instagram je veux un produit qui
me fait qu'il ya de la qualité
effectivement en terme de vidéo lors
vous il ya un truc est vraiment bien
c'est que votre instagram et intégrée de
attendant votre application prado ce qui
fait que lorsqu'on va exporter
directement fait une photo on va être en
passe directement par instagram
on va pas subir des espèces de
compression au rite qui au final donne
un résultat vraiment pas bon donc là je
te parle d'un programme qui aujourd'hui
quand même et est important mais d'une
manière générale on le voit tu prends
des réseaux comme pas forcément youtube
mais d'éthique top il ya beaucoup de
vidéos c'est extrêmement important
d'avoir de la vidéo de qualité
comment vous positionnez vous par
rapport à ça aujourd'hui juste juste
dire que je fais du full hd toi je passe
sur de la guica je perçois quelqu'un
joue sur du full hd déjà tous vraiment
de super qualité et on parle de qualité
vidéo mais aussi la qualité du micro
vraiment vous positionner par rapport à
ça pour nous c'est hyper important de ce
passionnant terme de d'uzès comme tu
l'as dit pour les pour les consommateurs
et pas uniquement de
les fiches techniques donc c'est pour ça
que
il ya toujours la partie micro qui
travaillent et toujours la partie bâti
des textes d'application qu'ils aient
travaillé et si je peux donner un
exemple de chose qui va dans ce sens
c'est qu'avant par exemple sur la vidéo
4k weck est toujours 4e jeudis qui est
toujours disponible à l'avant comme à
l'arrière de nos produits avant pour
passer d'un du capteur arrière au
capteur frontal fallait faire pause et
recommencer sa vidéo pour pouvoir se
filmer à l'avant oui hélas par exemple
l'idée c'est qu'on peut switcher de l'un
à l'autre sans dans la même vidéo du
coup tu peut switcher d'une caméra haute
c'est grâce à tourner xénon 60 calcul
sans arrêter la vidéo et ça c'est des
choses qu'on montre même pas aux
conférences parce que ça va peut-être
plaire à certaines audiences qui
utilisent cette fonction là mais c'est
important qu'on le dise et qu'on le
mette en avant tu sens que pour les
créateurs contenu très clairement
exactement c'est ce tas de petites
choses qui est importante et quand ce
paraître photos et vidéos by k
c'est quelque chose qui est important en
terme de polyvalence aussi parce que des
vidéos wii casse et c'est très bien
comme tu l'as dit et l'équipement
commencent à arriver et say tap à 100
mais fait d'extraire des photos de 33
millions pixels de ces vidéos
ça permet un usage polyvalent qui est
intéressant est pas limitée à une puce
techniques de présentation cool bon
merci gérer le deuxième ouais cool on
hâte de voir ça de ton côté par les
fonctions qui ressorte est justement de
les y attend lusage oui car dixit marc
tous cas merci à toi je sais pas ce que
vous pensez vous en tout cas de ce qu'on
trouve un peu à l'arrière c'est
différenciant ça change un peu ce qu'on
a ce qu'ils nous proposent et ça c'est
vraiment dans ce qui se fait
actuellement
on a des choses qui sont assez
similaires avec le pixel 4 toujours pas
de prise jack ici bon c'est pas
extrêmement grave capteur d'empreintes
digitales sous l'écran comment vous le
trouvez est ce que vous trouvez bien oui
non quoi comment marquer moi tout ça on
va en commentaire et puis abonnez-vous
parce qu'on se retrouve dès demain pour
continuer bien évidemment par les tec a
parlé de samsung ont passé tel examen
pour se tester
j'arrive plus de points on va se tester
les galaxies bold très rapidement d'ici
quelques jours on va parler du sed flip
également d'ici quelques jours et après
maintes choses intéressantes à dire
durant les tests les prises en main les
zones boxing enfin il ya plein de choses
du côté de samsung il n'y a pas que
samsung je suis plein d'autres
lancements qui vont pas tarder à arriver
n'est ce pas déjà qu'un sens et
j'embrasse devant débuter demain produit
hier par les flics
ces banques qui des abonnés
m